to get some suggestions guys over here I
I missed the first word of that but a
toddler having a tantrum in target what
lovely alliteration thank you very much
a toddler target tantrum so there you
guys over here so that was Santa but
pretty high what are you gonna hit us
with what was that sumo wrestling I I
like that one sumo wrestling toddler
having at our tantrum and target front
middle that's that see these are both
very obvious and boring Boris Johnson
American politics has been more fun no
no glues that do you say that you say
Battlestar Gallactica cool
make noise have you seen Battlestar
Galactica a bunch of nerds weirdly I
haven't seen it's by the fact I'm I
seemed a bit early but we'll take that
Battlestar Galactica Topol having a
tantrum in target sumo wrestling let's
get one one more what does that Essex
okay no one here knows what that is but
that's fine if you don't know what we
have a show called The Only Way Is Essex
which is essentially your kind of Jersey
Shore I think that's right yeah are you
from Essex my friend okay okay we just
like to check how rude I can be about
Essex Essex sumo wrestlers Tom's having
tantrums and target battlestar galactica
let's get one more
Gertrude's teeth
was that is that referencing a joke I
wasn't here for who's Gertrude an old
lady and we're rapping about her teeth
okay cool Gertrude's teeth a toddler
having a tantrum in target sumo
wrestling bouts da Galactica and Essex
this then lovely people of comedy magic
club to close out evening a little
freestyle rap that is made up on the
spot based entirely on those suggestions
do not worry it will not be anywhere
near as atrociously bad as you are
expecting it to be can we play that
track please silent and running from the
Cylons try and run away being like oh
why was there a spin-off maybe cold
Firefly I've got two facts and I spot
them there Battlestar Galactica India
it's like Star Trek but more nerdy this
is life singing with less worthy that's
okay
I go to Tokyo one bump Bailey's with a
fat dude sumo wrestling I put my chest
and my muscles in I'm in a big kind of
sumo wrestling ring people stand around
the side to hide my genitals but got my
bum crack you can see you when I bend
over right at the back I start to sway
in defeat me I look like the wrestler
called Russia key or Rafiki nah he's a
mandrill we move on now yet the voice so
shrill of a target to me you should
leave your kid there just run and be
free let be picked up by a predator just
shake it around take it out of there
this will teach you a lesson for one in
a toy shall we now at the volume you
voice just annoys everybody now you lost
wandering around the aisles who prey
from your eyes tiny little child no one
loves me I won't be found big tantrum
fists and feet on the ground are so sad
and what comes next he's abducted and
raised east of the UK was a fake tan
yeah you say we had to show they're all
blond bimbos they go out there and drink
yeah getting cat holes that's a drug
reference taking care of in we've got
one drug link Oh professor in getting
that stuff yeah next thing to do what
was the last one that we need to run
through okay yet if I believe never
better but I assume the Gertrude's teeth
a fake of course attached to a gums get
some fix it and don't suck your thumb
otherwise they will spit out here you
really ought to disinfect them put them
in a glass of water overnight so the
bacteria goes Gertrude she's really good
when she blows
[Applause]